it's been three months since apple
released their iphone 12 lineup and now
that all the hype has started to die
down
let's talk about what's changed what we
might have been wrong about
if you should buy the iphone 12 instead
of a 12 pro or a cheaper 11
and the biggest issue that i have with
this phone that is partially available
and at the end of the day if you should
just wait for the iphone 13. when apple
launched four phones earlier this year
i thought that the 12 was almost
redundant
mixed in with the cheaper and smaller
iphone 12 mini that people were asking
for
for years and the iphone 12 pro which
seemed to offer a lot more for not that
big of a price hike
especially after that hidden 30
activation charge
that apple and some carriers tacked on
without mentioning it
at the event which i'm still salty about
and you should be too
i figured the iphone 12 wouldn't be
anywhere near as hot of a seller as the
iphone 11
simply because it's no longer at that
great price point of
but instead costs up to 130 more
and the iphone 11 is still available now
for
599 but now that sales figures are out
the outcome is interesting i figured
that a lot of budget-minded people would
still go for the 11 since it's still a
very capable phone with a fast chip and
dual cameras just like the 12
and at the same time the 12 has never
been as close to the price point of the
pro model
last year the 11 pro cost more than the
11
and even if you upgraded to 128
gigabytes of storage it was still
250 dollars more this year the iphone 12
could be up to 830 bucks and then if you
bump up your storage
you're spending 880 meaning that the 12
pro costs only 120 dollars more so
should you just buy a pro
well let's see what else you're getting
starting off with the most noticeable
differences
you're getting a very premium stainless
steel frame that almost no other brands
offer
not only does it look good but it also
offers more protection
and less noticeable scratches and dents
compared to aluminum
now you do lose the wide variety of
color options but you get the more
premium ones like the pacific blue or
gold
the back looks a lot sleeker as well
with the matte glass finish that is
fingerprint resistant
and the camera cutout is glossy for a
really clean look
and of course the biggest differences
come in the camera department
along with the standard and wide camera
we have a telephoto lens for zoom shots
and a lidar sensor which is used for ar
not only that but the pro can shoot
dolby vision at up to 60 frames per
second instead of 30
and you can also shoot apple prora which
are both just software locks since the
12 and 12 mini
have the same camera sensors and
processors now three months ago i
thought that these extra features
clearly made the iphone 12 pro worth the
extra money
and apple was shooting themselves in the
foot by raising the iphone 12
price by so much compared to the
previous year and at the same time
apple is offering the iphone 12 mini
which is basically the same phone but
with a smaller display for a hundred
dollars less
and the only downside that i noticed is
battery life
and even still it's only about a one
hour difference of screen
on time and with my use i have to charge
both during the day
anyway so it seemed like another great
option if you don't want to go for the
pro
since almost everything else is the same
so now that we've had some time
did the iphone 12 turn out to be the odd
middle child
or did apple know what they were doing
here's what ended up happening
first off sales figures started coming
out and even though apple fans were
begging for another small
flagship phone for years the iphone 12
mini turned out to be an
absolute flop and in my video about why
the iphone 12 mini failed
i talked about a few issues that we had
with the phone and why i could no longer
use it the biggest
issue among the list was the 5g antenna
even though it has the same exact specs
as a 12 the reception was noticeably
worse
and in multiple areas where i had
service with the bigger iphones
i didn't with the 12 mini and that was
the biggest deal breaker for me but for
most people
i think the size is just way too small
now
apple has been focusing on large phones
for years now and even though it is a
pain getting used to a larger phone
once you're used to it it is very hard
even harder
to go back to something smaller because
of that the 12 mini sales have been so
low at only about 5 of the total iphone
sales
that apple will now have to pay samsung
for the lack of volume of these oled
displays
so it turns out most people are skipping
the mini but what about
the pro well sales figures have shown
that the iphone 12 pros account for
about 20
of total iphone sales and that seems to
be a total of 20 percent
so split between the phones and if i had
to guess
i would say that the max model will pull
more of that twenty percent
just because it's the only one that has
a larger display and the extra features
now go ahead and take a guess
how much of the total iphone sales
including the older iphone models
the standard iphone 12 captured go ahead
and comment down below
the iphone 12 was 27
of total iphone sales not only that but
because of the iphone 12 apple once
again became
number one in phone sales for the first
time since 2016
and had a revenue of over 100 billion
dollars for the first time
ever so looks like you guys out there
spoke with your wallet
and iphone 12 became the king of the
iphones
selling roughly three times more than
the pro it's crazy
so the question is why is that and would
i as a reviewer still recommend spending
the extra cash on the pro like i did
before
or maybe saving money and get the 11 or
maybe
if you're on defense just don't even
upgrade this year and wait for the 13.
let me start out by saying that there is
no way that i would buy an 11
even if the price is so tempting sure
the camera hardware is basically the
same but the a14 processor has made a
huge difference
especially in ultra wide shots and the
new design not only makes it look modern
but it's also thinner and smaller
although the screen
is the same size and the oled screen is
so much better than the lcd from before
real world battery life has also
improved but the biggest difference for
me
is that the modem not only allows for
full sub 6
mid band and millimeter wave support so
this phone is future proof in that
aspect but it also has
much faster regular lte that has had
much better reception than the iphone
11s now what about the pro models
if we skip the stainless steel and the
cleaner looks
the biggest thing that pushed me towards
them are the better cameras
since the display is pretty much exactly
the same other than a little bit of
artificial brightness limitation
which isn't noticeable most of the time
now while i do
really like having a third telephoto
camera and i thought that i would always
want one
i've recently found that shooting
standard photos and cropping
in seems to be resulting in noticeably
better photos than before
now i'm not sure if apple has been
quietly updating the algorithm or using
diffusion more often
but the photos coming out look fantastic
now sure
if you want to zoom in 10 times you are
gonna see a bigger difference but a
two-time zoom shot looks quite good
with the standard iphone 12 lens as for
portrait shots i've been using the 1x
lens
way more often than telephoto because
images turn out so clean
compared to the zoomed in one and the
one thing that i thought i would miss
the most
is taking nighttime portraits but going
back over my camera roll it turns out
that it don't actually take them very
often
so maybe i wouldn't miss them as much as
i expected looking over
how i've been using my pro and seeing
how much better the 12 sales are
it seems like most people either don't
want to spend more
or maybe they just don't really need the
extra features that come with the pro
model and looking back i think that most
people would be happy with the 12.
the compromises aren't as bad as i
expected and
one thing that i am really appreciating
now more than ever
is just how surprisingly lightweight it
feels
compared to the pro which is much much
heavier all while still
feeling very premium the iphone 12 gives
you so much more
this year than apple has in previous
years you get that perfect all-around
screen
size for most people a gorgeous high-res
oled display and the same exact antennas
and modem as the pro phones
which it was never that case before so
there are way less compromises this year
than before now sure the cost did go up
by up to 129
but i think that the price increase is
definitely justified for a much more
future proof phone
my only complaint about it would be the
software lock camera features
such as the pro raw and the 60fps dolby
vision
and the only hardware issue that i have
with it is apple's ceramic shield
that they are advertising right now
which is tougher but it scratches much
easier than before and that's not an
issue with just this phone
it's with all of the iphone 12 so i
would highly recommend
a 10 screen protector which i'll go
ahead and link down in the video
description below
and finally should you wait to buy an
iphone 13
instead now in my opinion the answer is
no
the biggest improvements like pro motion
for example will likely be coming
only to the pro versions and we will
still have this notch
next year it just might be getting
slightly smaller
battery life will get slightly better as
well but overall the upgrade will be
much smaller and much less significant
than going from an iphone 10r or an 11
to the iphone 12. overall the iphone 12
has been an absolute killer for apple
and for the masses as well
with tons of my personal friends
upgrading to them and being super happy
with it
even if they went from a more premium
iphone 10 or 10s
and three months later this phone is
looking even better than before go ahead
and let me know your thoughts
down below would you spend the extra on
an iphone 12 pro or maybe just buy a
mini instead
i want to see your guys's opinions if
you want to see
our video and all the leaks and rumors
for the iphone 13
we have that video right over there
that's been max and i'll catch you in
the next video